okay for people joining this live stream
this is a meeting about welcome language
incremental language development
we actually have two back-to-back
meetings this afternoon
one is incremental language development
the other is language completeness and
consistency
um although i think they are
separately tagged yes um
okay let's launch here tree form
so the first topic is a question you
posted at um
asking about how to represent atomic
heads
in reform
and we have chance to discuss that
the same question applies to expression
graph
yep um well
let's understand what what is happening
right now i mean so right now
if i say nest list uh
you know fx 5 or something
and i say tree form oh the
this will work okay that's what that
does but now if i were to do it the
other way around if i were to say
um
if i were to make this a headdress so to
speak if i were to say
let's see what is the right thing to do
here if i would say hash of f is that
right
am i getting this the right way around
yeah something like that
right am i doing this right yeah
that that is boring right
so question is what should we be doing
there
charles or anybody here
charles here yes i'm here
um well for me at the time or at least
what i think is is main
it depends of the use and application of
you know
what we what we what we are looking at
if we look at it as you know an
evaluation three
sure we can just break it down like you
know a
kind of you know we'll generate a three
which is you know appropriate for a
depth first traversal like we do in the
evaluator
otherwise um i mean it's purely based on
the application
that's nice so you're saying you're
saying
imagine you were the evaluator
right i mean what is the recursive
process that you go through so this tree
is representing the recursive
so so for example if we were to do that
let me let me just
um i should be saving this someplace
different is this saved in dropbox does
anybody know
uh it's not right now okay
um let's put this
yeah this is going to go in separate
place i'm going to put this in a
different place
okay okay um
okay so here's here's the concept
the concept would be if you were tagging
the parts of this so
i mean how would i display this can i do
it with a
a map with a side effect can i put a
number in here
how do i know what order these things
are being traversed in
but you you're suggesting that every
edge here
represents a a step in the traversal
done by the evaluator and so
the traversals in here are us are
sub-traversals so to speak
as being represented in something like
this
is that right yes that's one way yes
what the heck is that line there doing
i think that's that's a another box
it is that this internal so that goes
into steps
and the new box is too large
so you're saying okay so do we have
anybody from design here
could we could we try and find jeremy or
somebody else from design
yeah sure you try to get him yep
okay i mean i think this is basically
the right idea
it's something like this anybody object
to that
no i i i think it's yes it's it's a
natural thing to to actually create a
new tree for the new height inside
right right but it just needs some
design
go ahead but in that case
roughly speaking the tree structure
doesn't change it's just a different um
rendering basically am i correct
i i think so well yeah for expression
tree
i'm not expression graph i'm not so sure
where do you have expression graph here
i don't i don't have examples of
expression graph
okay but i could make an expression
graph for for each of these
so this will make a mess right
okay so the expression graphs here will
be
right and if i were to say expression
graph hash
vertex labels goes to automatic
yeah that looks wonderful right it's all
good
i mean i i don't know whether
there's an argument that says that by
default we should
put in vertex labels an expression graph
to be placed vertex labels if you
understand what i'm saying
charles how would you do that putting
the vertex labels inside the boxes
oh um what you have to do uh place
automatic comma centered
please um probably name or just name
you probably will have to automatically
adjust the
text size and such well
it's not automatic i mean you're saying
i i should do it here for example
okay that's really weird okay all right
i get it
okay all right so now
um you're suggesting an expression graph
what should it do in this case
how do we have the notion of a sub graph
here
do you see what i'm saying yep
i don't know um is there such a thing
charles some sort of sub graph inside
well for the rendering yes we can do the
highlighting the point was you know do
we actually want it that
you can actually detect that in the
structure of the calf
well i think that's what heads arrow
true or false which should represent
okay i would think in other words
does expression graph currently have a
heads option
uh no
reform doesn't either and that's the
second topic
of the discussion further okay
it's it's a separate topic but it's
related to
to the to heads and the fact that
tree form doesn't align well with lay
with level and so i think
it would be nice to have a separate
function perhaps
that actually corresponds one-to-one to
level
so that we see the diagrams of what
expressions
are in level why doesn't it correspond
to level
so um i think it's easier in the
headstroke case
go a bit down and you see we
we call level there right we get these
three levels
if we try to do that with three form the
the heads and the expressions
are at different levels and it's
difficult to understand while
this level for my prototype there shows
the things out there right but also this
is like the transitive
reduction transitive closure of this
thing right i mean this thing is this
but this has all of the pieces you get
what i'm saying this has the whole
expression and then it has sub pieces
here
exactly but you see that it corresponds
perfectly with
the three uh results from level i
understand that seems like a good
functional positive function to me
i think you should put level four on the
function repository and link to it from
level
right because for example something i
noticed is that we don't have diagrams
in the page of level
i think it's a pity because it it would
be easier to understand
level indeed it would yes but i mean we
could call a functional positive
function for that i think
i can do that i can create effectively
this function and use it
there okay all right okay fine did we
manage to get somebody from design here
uh not yet i sent jeremy meeting at info
and gave him a call but no answer
he might have stepped away but hopefully
he joined soon
okay so so then for charles so what i'm
suggesting is that heads goes to true
will give the sub graph heads goes to
false we'll just treat it as atomic
does that make sense
this graph becomes a node in this case
the subgroup is goes to false the sub
graph is just a node
whose name is the composite head
if heads goes to true then it burrows
into the head so to speak and it becomes
a piece of the graph am i making sense
to charles do you understand yes yes
but i think it's not really a piece of
the graph is it's a node
which becomes a graph itself but how do
we represent i mean the only way we have
to represent that in a graph is a
is a sub graph right right so we
roughly speaking we flatten it otherwise
it's a hyper graph per se you know do
not have another embedded graph
which we can't represent yet
i see because in the tree form
representation
it's a whole box that becomes that
contains internally another tree
exactly right we can't do that for a
graph we don't have a way to make a
graph within a graph other than
you know we could tag those edges we
could tag the edges differently
we could put tags on the edges just for
fun so to speak
for expression graph personally i think
that one's going to want
you know this will be pretty decent to
just have i think it'll be nice to have
different colors in some way
and and you know the head of the head of
the head
okay here's what i think we should do i
think if we can have the edges be
different
going inside ahead then they are going
just
uh you know as as a um
a normal expression that would make
sense
charles d do you see what i'm saying um
yes
and we would do that with tagging and
with the default
you know default rendering
that makes sense yes
okay
to add a little bit more of uh we add a
little bit more of
information visualization there more
something more specific
that's what we're saying yes we need to
wait for somebody from design to finish
this off so i think we've
got to go on to the next topic here and
we'll loop back to this hopefully
later on in this in this uh meeting okay
is there anything else we need to
discuss about this
uh no i don't know whether charles wants
to
stay or we can call him i think yeah we
can call them back when we get
and if jeremy isn't available we should
get billy or somebody
yeah sure i just messaged billy see if
he can join
okay okay so the next topic is data
center with chris
right i sent you two notebooks um you
should first open the one
marked prototype and the prototype build
who am i those that would okay prototype
in the prototype build okay so i've
implemented data set editing and i want
to run it by you
oh cool
very cool well i'll say that even more
when i
see it um
so we had talked about using a table
view to do that that's not what it did
i implemented something you think is
better
okay
so if you just evaluate that expression
okay if you if you right click on one of
those there's an edit item in the menu
so if you just want to do a quick spot
edit you can do that
hit return and there it is
but you can also tab you can do the same
thing and then you can tab to other
elements and edit those as well so you
actually in other words you're bringing
up on how will this work in the cloud
i haven't even thought about that yet
you know do you know how many times
i hear that oh i haven't even thought
about that yet
about the cloud it's really
disappointing i mean the
okay obviously it's got to work in the
cloud it's got to work in the cloud
okay can i see a more non-trivial data
set yes well so i
just keep going down this list of topics
there's a number of things that i want
to show you
okay well hold on let me look at this
one a little bit more carefully okay
so i'm here i mean to me and this is
something
i mean we we'd really want noah or
somebody here to opine on this but this
is
this should have an attached cell that
is
that has things like you know has a
button that says edit
basically in my opinion you shouldn't
have to go to the right click menu to do
that
do you understand what i'm saying yeah i
understand what you're saying and i
considered that i think this is
a little more elegant well
we need it look if we have a toolbar
that only happens on hover
then we have best of both worlds i don't
think there's anything wrong with this
but um okay so i can tab through these
and um if you look at the next example
so you can tab through those but you
also you have access to the entire data
set in the
editor dialog so this example doesn't
have any doesn't have multiple levels
but if you do you can drill down you can
scroll
that thing so now i go right click what
the hell
you have to right click on a on a thing
okay but
uh we already lost the game here well
you know
right now we're running right now i have
talked to i have a jira ticket in with
the front end people i would like to be
able to attach interactive behaviors to
grid cells
it's a is a technical issue that you can
resolve but then but then
look we've already got a bunch of stuff
done here we we need an attached cell
that comes up on hover
yeah okay that that way we can solve
this problem well i don't even know
where do i go to get this click click
click on an item click a number
okay and then what oh edit i'd never be
able to figure that out
okay um you can edit anything in the
data set now
before you dismiss it
so i can go down here i can be
walking down with that can i add a row
to the data set
no is that temporary or is that a
that okay so the cursor is doing the
wrong thing here i'm clicking after 66
and the cursor is not moving to after
66.
uh yeah it's because yeah okay
okay now what just happened there
because i i edited i removed it
and then oh good nice so what is that
in fact what is that creature
missing okay you can edit it and you'll
see the
input form
nice nice i like the fact that it has
the selection
you know preserves the selection there
yeah it makes it easy to do a spot at it
okay why can't i resize that window i
should be able to
there's an easy way to make that happen
i think
yeah why do you want to resize them
because because i might want this thing
to get longer
somehow you want you want to resize the
not just the window but the data set
that's right you want to see more
scrolling area
yes i think so and in fact the ux that
will be really nice here
is to have one of those side you know i
don't know what they're called you know
thumb thumb grabby things on the side
that i could then pull out
to make to just change the rather than
zero right to change the scrolling area
right and and failing that in the attach
toolbar i'd like to be able to adjust
that but i particularly like to be able
to adjust that in the
by by explicitly thumbing it in and out
so to speak
yeah um
okay uh
um
let's see
so every you know a lot of items in
dataset have special formatting
uh it's turned off in the editor and
everything is given an input form
okay i have no idea whether i
collect selected the right thing but
let's go there
i have no sense of whether that's the
correct behavior
it's probably the correct behavior well
so there's two issues one is
um you know if if there's some special
form we would have to have some
way of parsing backwards from the
special form to the original
let me point out by the way in terms of
my width thing this is the case where
it's going to you know something might
go really really wide here and have to
be dot dot dotted
otherwise it would go bonkers right yep
yep i can easily invent that
so this has got to be resizable yeah
um but the other issue is even
i mean for some complex forms the user
is just going to have no hope of editing
it
okay why why does this not resize
um because it's thumb nailed i don't
know
i have to check that out
okay whatever that is
did resize okay so that's not going to
have an effect because
you're you're for you're reformatting
the source data but the
you know the formatting of an image and
dataset is thumbnail
i see right but if i were to extract it
i would get different things now
if you were to extract that image
yeah yes you should okay
yeah i mean i don't know what to do with
this i i don't know what you do with
that
i mean that that's an issue i mean this
is look
okay here's what i think should happen
okay i think there should be a way to
peel this off into a form notebook
right for really industrial scale
editing of things that are really long
complicated peel it off and make it a
form notebook
just that item you mean no i mean the
whole data set
okay i don't know what i don't know what
it means to make it a form notebook
it means it makes it a notebook you
understand you know what a form notebook
is right
i know what forms are on the web no no
no no no
no no no no no no okay so you haven't
been paying attention to that project so
probably you should join the meeting
that's happening this afternoon about
that
i mean form notebooks are notebooks that
have tagged content
and are you know immediately scrapable
do you understand what i'm saying okay
so then each of these things becomes a
section
in the form notebook you do whatever
editing you want and then you press ok
and it turns back into this i see okay
and that would be my suggestion for what
to do rather than you can't get there
from here
that would be my suggestion for what to
do in this case does that work with
multiple levels and ragged and
all that stuff no it's it's purely a it
will purely work only with one level
i can work with a column i mean maybe
it's not quite the right suggestion but
i think
maybe the right thing to do here is to
say i mean if you can do a nested
um you know dialogue-y thing
that might be possible where you can
open it in a notebook you get what i'm
saying
open just that particular uh you know
grid grid element in a notebook
okay i don't have an opinion about that
i would doubt that
i would doubt that's a good idea because
because it's changing the data i mean
well no this would only this would only
be
going into the editor dialogue you'd
apply normal so that you get
like a rectangular array you can edit it
and going back it would turn it back why
don't i want to edit it as a sponsor
right
because it's because if it's not
input form it's an ugly thing you can't
edit if it is input form it's a cryptic
thing that you don't know how to edit
but i think in the specific case of
sparse array to give it as
a sparse array with sparse array of
various i mean i don't know how you
exactly build that as an output form
but i think that would be the useful
thing because otherwise you blow it up
you know it's a million by million space
array but it has
three elements in it yeah and that will
blow it up
all right what is remove type argument
from nested data sets
well since everything is is presented in
input form if you have a data set in a
data set
you get its input form which has this
ugly type argument in it
which is irrelevant to editing it should
be removed that's really a note to
myself
okay
okay okay you've already seen the next
one missing values
now this this is not working in the
prototype so i just put screenshots in
here if you have an item display
function
in this case it gives you the integer
name of the contents when you edit
it shows you the underlying data but
then
when you're done editing you of course
you get the
display maybe there should be a visual
indication that what you are seeing is
not what you're going to get
um like what a color background for
example
okay or i i think it's a it's a luxury
feature but i mean i think
having something that indicates
oh i don't know people are gonna more
likely just be confused like why is
there a colored background there
yeah all right okay don't worry about it
okay hidden items work similarly it
unhides
when you edit and then it hides again
nice
so you can evaluate that if you have a
data set that is populated with
placeholder you can use it as a like an
entry
thing how edit
choose edit okay this is got to be an
attached cell
by the way in that particular case when
you click the placeholder i don't really
see why it wouldn't just
come up with like bring up the editor
yeah now what about table view for some
of these i mean what about if i wanted
this to be a table view
you know it seems to me that a peel off
of from these things
that could peel off as a table view
could peel off as whatever else might be
useful
you mean you want a table view in the
editor
that's what i'm thinking maybe i'm wrong
i think the thing to do
is you know how do i do the sorting
table view of data set
how do i sort right click the header and
sort
nice these have got to have mouse overs
of some kind it's got to have a mouse
over that indicates that you can right
click it it's just completely unobvious
that you can right click it
well it does it turns blue
that means a click to me not a right
click
yeah okay i never figure out the right
click
and never figure out the right click
there's got to be some way there's got
to be some
you know affordance thingy that shows me
that you know there's an alternative to
right clicking that comes up when i'm
hovering over this
i mean i can't think of any precedent
for that there's not usually a visual
indication of
right you can write i know because this
isn't i'm
because i'm saying the right click is
not the only op
the only way to get to that ux
see what i'm saying why don't you do one
iteration with noah
about this okay if you can't figure this
out i mean i
i think that it's either something that
comes up down below here
or perhaps better it's something that
comes up
on you know near the thing you're
clicking you see what i'm saying
yeah by the way this functionality is
quite spectacular does it scale well
i mean i haven't tried it on huge data
sets it'll it's not going to be any
slower than just
you know regular data set display is
okay so what's this now so if there's an
alighted form
like so yeah this is the case where you
really do need the
um the edit button but if you if you get
to the editor which you can't do by
right clicking there
you have to right click somewhere else
this is a joke i mean i'm i'm
desperately trying to find a place i can
right click
to get to the editor right right click
on the header
right so there's a lighted items to edit
in a lighted item you click that item
and it takes you to
down one level where you can add it yeah
that's nice
premium on our live stream says video
games do this quite well
which what's this and what do they do
give us a suggestion so i'm not totally
thrilled with this modal character of
this thing
although i understand there isn't a lot
of choice
yeah i don't know why it does this
either this is something i inherited
from tally
um and you know i never know so
so which thing are you are you talking
about
this presentation is text rather than as
a like
formatted items no no i'm saying the
modal thing about the way the other
i see the modal editor dialog yeah
is there any any alternative ux here
well i mean you could imagine it sort of
coming up in place
i mean one reason for a modal dialogue
is you want the editing to be done
before the notebook is closed
because you don't want to have
unresolved editing
i mean that's a whole other layer having
to store all that information
yeah i understand um
i i would really like to get some more
ux review of this i mean this is quite
lovely and
really quite lovely but another reason
for the modal dialogue is
you know the data is presented
differently so
yeah i understand that yeah i'm just not
sure you know
i don't know how we do that in the cloud
for example
i mean i it's probably possible
now what am i supposed to see here yeah
same thing
just the alighted items okay now
something is wrong with the selection
here see
it the selection selecting before
doesn't see this is i'm selecting i know
what you mean right there
yep yeah um yes
that's gonna be hard to correct i know
why it's happening but it's gonna be
hard why is it happening
because there's an input field in that
grid and the input field doesn't fill
the entire space of the experience
you need to talk to the to john and so
on about that i thought there was a way
we
figured out to deal with that okay
ah scoof okay so return
i see return does the okay yeah
so i couldn't return inside one of those
things if
i had a syntactically um
okay so if i had this syntactically a
string for example
or if i had this syntactically
uh you might be able to use splafferoo
yeah it's not a splaferoo it's saying
you entered an incomplete expression
i know because i was trying to put a new
line into a string
yeah yeah i think you need to figure out
figure that case out and then just not
you know return if it's inside a
syntactically incomplete thing should
not
shift return might actually work i don't
know
shift return that would be the opposite
use of shift return from the usual one
or some modifier return might i mean
it's whatever the
whatever an input field does by default
well option returned in control return
yeah
no no that's even more bizarre control
return is
okay so you need to look at that i don't
know what the right thing to do is there
actually a point made on my live stream
double click to go into an editor is
common
yes that would be nice to make work
that'd be nice to make work and
particularly if you
you know even if you just had a hover if
you're in here double
you know since you're hovering to
produce something there
somehow yeah double click would be nice
it's an obvious yeah thing right
um but we still need more
discoverability and i think the right
way to do discoverability is with
um an attached cell
okay okay okay this is really nice
really nice functionality i just hope
it's robust
um okay do i need to see the other the
other item that you put through is that
the same thing or a different thing no
it's a
that's a different there's there's one i
there one important item in that
notebook especially
okay is that going to the current build
of the project yeah just like the
current build
so i'm looking at you asked for themes
dataset themes and i'm looking at that
now
so i'm going on pto end of next week and
i'll be back
the last week of september um
i can put in the infrastructure for
themes but somebody needs to actually
design the themes themselves
and okay so the obvious candidate for
that is
tim shuttlebauer okay uh so the question
is can you put on this project
uh to work on it i have no idea i'm not
his manager i don't know
well do i need to talk to roger about
that then i would assume so i don't
really know i i don't know what
um um i i'm sorry it's not who's project
managing this
uh this meeting uh devin and i can
i can ask about tim's availability yeah
and if not to him i would say it was
somebody in jeremy's team
um
um i have a list of example themes in
here if you
if you want to look at this we can look
at that if not uh you can go well
i'm interested yeah i'm interested to
see these so the question is what would
you use themes for
um you can just evaluate that whole
thing if you want
um okay striped rows like a line printer
yeah that's nice
so we also need name themes right
yeah i mean these these are just
examples of things you
might want to do using themes
i think we need a separate meeting about
this because i think this is going to be
yeah i mean themes that this is a theme
that shows
the value you know colors the values so
to speak
color by value yeah
um
well i think so theme like heat map
seems like a reasonable theme
yeah i mean i think a theme like line
printer except maybe nobody will get
that anymore
we're just dinosaurs the
you get that right chris i get the name
yeah
well i mean that this thing here is like
line printer paper
yes yes exactly i mean but nobody called
out today
what would they call it i don't know
like
the row registration is you know i don't
know
i think it'd be kind of cute to call it
line printer
i mean you know all these themes are um
um okay but i think i think some of
these
i think you know we've had a marketing
theme for the um
we have a web theme a marketing theme
those kinds of things
for graphics those are things that we
certainly can have here but there are
specialized things like this heat map
that seems really useful
um
wow that's funky
yeah why not well this is really a good
good project but i i
let's try to get a separate meeting and
go through an inventory what possible
themes are okay
okay see if tim can work on this
otherwise somebody in the um
uh um in jeremy's group
okay yeah um
um this is really a minor issue um
so so the issue is there's no way to in
the item display function to get at
the default formatting for an item if
you want if you want to incorporate that
in
something so i've added a fourth
argument to the item display function
which is the formatted form the default
formatted form of a thing
oops what come that
that should not have happened oh you're
not in the
i'm not on the prototype bill i'm just
in the regular belt uh
yeah okay all right what's this that
doesn't seem controversial
yeah that's that's fine that's fine you
don't need to look at that
what is this just for your information
um
the most reported bug was dataset
alighting things
when people didn't want them to be
alighted so i've changed the precedence
of
item display function so now it is
applied before elision
so if you if something gets a lighted
you don't want it to be the way to
correct that is use
item display function essentially
identity and that and that
and that fixes it prevents solution now
i didn't hear but wood in the new belt
yeah
well didn't in that build either that is
strange
um
oh maybe i didn't click it no it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
okay it works for me i don't know what
uh maybe i've got a newer version okay
anyway that's what it's saying okay okay
um look at the procedural thing let's
combine
i don't think there's any reason to have
the let's let's ask the lcc folk to join
us here in a few minutes let's we don't
need to break this into two separate
meetings they're gonna lie together
anyway okay
a suggestion from ali that we look at
color plots from the seabourn
library and so on and yeah we should
look at i'm sure that
tim and some will kind of do a a study
of
of relevant um
uh places and books and so on
all right um okay did we
did we end up getting jeremy or not but
we have billy at least
yeah we have billy and charles is back
okay all right so let's go back to this
topic here
i have a feeling this is going to need
jeremy that
we're trying to display
nested
how did you make this sorry how did you
make this picture can i make one too
yes it's just mapping three form on the
head
so you see what i do i just mapping on
the whole expression and at position
zero
okay okay can we do one that's more
deeply
nested like an alpha f of f more deeply
nested
yes just keep having longer lists of
zeros
you see the next example zero zero comma
zero comma empty list
so that's a that's the key idea i see
i see okay fine so
so this is it's like map at all heads
okay hold on so that's that
and now you're saying that if i do this
oh i see what you're saying that that's
the list of
so if i do this here
that's a big mess
i don't know what that's doing
that's really weird
okay so the basic question is
we are looking at the head of a head of
a head
and that tool tip is completely wrong as
well the head of a head
and i i mean this yellow is not really
making it very
i think this yellow could be retired i
don't think the cielo is very good
i think it also might help to round
these corners i'm not sure
billy want to comment on any of this
yeah the rounded corners i think
would help the yellow if if there's
other things that are connected to it
i'd
maybe want to see those other things
first but
yeah well what's happening is what we're
trying to do is the head of a head of a
head
okay so it's yellow with a with a yellow
thing inside it
okay like this right so the question is
how do we do that
it's kind of yellow all the way down now
maybe what we can do is just composite
uh alpha channels here effectively and
have at least
getting darker and darker yellow if it's
yellow in the first place
that'd be interesting right because this
is
kind of a not working thing right in my
view
again this would look better with
rounded corners but can we simulate this
probably not easily but did
jose you understand what i'm saying here
that the
using i mean to distinguish that inner
piece by using a darker yellow
or or somehow having a varying color
palette
right that essentially what we're doing
is we're simply
putting
that object in there but with its color
palette kind of
one parameter family of color palettes
going off into
some you know either dark yellow or some
other direction
right um perhaps they could alternate
it's an important thing is that you see
a transition from one to the other
we're back to line printers
um well okay so so but the basic point
is we're going to need a color map
and maybe the way we do that is we say
with heads goes to
true in expression graph
no this is for expression graph this is
heads goes to
false right then
does this become okay this is tree form
with heads goes to i would say true
false will be the previous diagram
yes false has no
uh head burrowing so to speak
whereas true okay so heads goes to true
then causes that to happen and causes us
and in that case we could have
potentially some kind of color function
in there as well that specifies by depth
what the color should be
map it's head depth right it's weird
but i think parameterizing that might be
useful i mean we could have a method
option for the time being
to do that right so that in principle
you can specify
any uh color map for this
make sense
just by you know depth head depth
and then it indexes into a color map
um okay
well so sounds like we need a few you
know some choices of colors and then for
the implementation we just need to
to index into that
okay um
uh someone on our live stream is saying
steve is saying fan fold paper equals
line printer
that's not the only point the point is
that that
i don't even know why they did it i mean
i think they did it for exactly the same
reason we're doing it to have
alternating colors
to just make it clearer where the where
the lines are
um
okay ethan is pointing out fonts don't
scale
nicely in these graphs you mean in
these graphs here i think fonts do okay
there well um
his graphs i don't know which graphs
we're talking about yeah for some reason
these graphs don't look very pretty i
don't know why
well they're kind of the default version
six
you know styling right we never updated
them since
well they need some they probably need a
facelift
um
i mean part of it's the size of it
you know the fact that it's a fixed
height in that first set of examples
doesn't help
well which which thing you mean the
fixed of title of these
yeah the overall height yeah i mean look
there is some facelift that's needed
for these i think in terms of design i
think and in terms of
um
i mean charles do you want to comment on
how this has
mapped or not mapped into i mean
our modern our modern thing
would be more what you get from
expression graph right
yes
um
well i mean if i just take some random
let's just do a table
let's do something to generate some
things let's do some table of integrals
or something
um
uh that's a little bit unconvincing for
expression graft is that really what we
want it to do
to go to not by default be a layered
digraph
um well we decided that when you get
bigger
you know it's harder to actually
you know well i would like to suggest
that it is a layered digraph but that
its aspect ratio has been modified
okay okay yep
um and now this
you know clearly if we if we go here and
we say
um uh
let's see we say vertex labels
to automatic
yeah it's a huge mess but not not
obviously wrong
um
right yeah this does look very very
dated here
um
ali is suggesting a light blue
background yeah it's uh
would that be consistent with other
things we've done
i don't know billy can you comment on
the question it's close to the
expression graph
there uh with the blue
yeah i understand but we want this we
need to modernize this
okay that's the bottom line here yeah
right
and there's a question in the tree form
the slightly bizarre choice that the
fonts scale like that is that the right
thing or not
i'm trying to remember what we did
recently with um
that work with i'm blanking on it right
now
but we did scaling there as well
yeah i think the scaling is a rainbow
you can't make publication quality graph
figures well you should send us some
examples
um
i'm sorry what were you saying brett i
was saying that i think the scaling
font size is a relatively recent
change i mean there's also the question
of whether in some cases what happens if
we say traditional form of this
what does that what does that do to that
styling there and so on
right yeah okay so anyway bottom line
let's get
you know some graphic design face
lifting done on
tree form but i think we've we've got a
pretty clear
direction for what to do with the uh
heads goes to true
business right there's also meanwhile we
had a complaint here
on our live stream from ali complaining
about long-standing bugs in graphs
especially
fine maximum flow when vertex capacity
is specified charles
can you comment on that um
sure we have some issue we are working
on so we hoping you know
to fix all of them in future versions
like in 12 2 for example um
yes so we have been you know since
version 12 we have been kind of focusing
on actually having all that so
yes you hope what is the issue with the
maximum flow
find maximum flow business what is that
um so while fast maxwell flow do
optimization
i mean it's a whole big optimization
problem and
there is some uh in a specific case
where when the curve have some weight
and the results are not correct so we
are trying to investigate why
i'm trying to fix it okay
good okay let's see we have just
i know we have people from the lcc
meeting who are just joining us but i
think that they
can survive through the last two items
here and perhaps contribute to them
um okay so we're done with the data set
stuff for now we're done with the
expression graph and treeform stuff so
let's go to echo evaluation
um right so i think this is something
you should open in the
prototype build because the styles are
there
or yeah just copy
i'm really excited about chris's
editable data sets really nice i wasn't
expecting that was going to come
together yeah it's nice yeah
so so what we see here is that the gila
mats are very
similar so it's kind of difficult to
distinguish one from the other
they are that is not working we still
have billy here
yes yes
yeah this is hopeless i mean
it's a good concept but it isn't working
right i think we need a color change
here for i mean this is the output
yes
um
what is this people are asking for ad
latex render boxes
and wrappers what does that mean how do
we demo can we demo
let's demo something cool ah that
doesn't work how do i
how do i get the the new um tech import
input stuff
anybody know i'm not sure it's in the
build yet
it was only ended yesterday i think
so maybe it's a is it a insert
item well it's definitely added
okay look at this guys of course i don't
know text so that's why i haven't used
it in years
let's see frac one x
wedge six minus one or something
uh does it turn into boxes like does it
call this yes
turns into boxes it uses it uses the 25
year old tech renderer
that we built for who knows what
but is it actually like a tech renderer
or is it is it turning into boxes and
rendering
boxes it's rendering through boxes okay
which is actually the right thing yeah
yeah
so if you evaluate that
whoops what happened oh it's a i i
didn't this isn't
a um input cell this is a text cell
um maybe it currently only works
in text the question is can you have
labels that are in
latex i would think you can although an
interesting question which this actually
raises
what you guys are raising is to have
something where the template
uh template string template things work
through the latex stuff that should be
thought through you understand what i'm
saying
so that you can have a string template
which automatically turns into
a um
later rendered pdf i don't know what
they're talking about
ethan is saying that sage math is
superior that's something i haven't
heard in a long time for
pure graph theory math well we should
find out what it is
maybe somebody should make a link it's
an open thing so we could just
uh could just throw it in as a piece of
extra stuff if it actually works
of course the problem is it might not
actually work and then it's not clear
what you do about it
um sorry stephen
one thing that comes to mind with that
evaluation that you have on screen um
what happens if you have another echo in
that evaluation
yeah okay well we'll worry about that in
a second
let's just deal with our tech input oh
sorry i thought you were over with this
sorry
i'm almost over with this
that seemed to work
so that's a piece of tech and we could
presumably say that thing
to the power of that thing
well let's see if i click that
and then i evaluate it it'll do the
right thing
i think it's pretty good um
i don't understand this latex random pdf
you can describe that more
more precisely than that would be good
but i don't know what that means
what's the question it's a question
about
graph labels with v sub i in latex
right so this is i think these are
people who want to substitute
tech fonts for our fonts when they
export
their graphics or graphs to
you know to a pdf and there's a
external package called matec
that does this should we be able to do
it
i think this is the totally wrong group
of people to answer that question
i mean brett may have some insight given
graphics but go ahead but brett do you
want to say something
um i mean i don't
know that i have a lot to say i mean
presumably it would relate to
whatever the let's not speculate but if
people
if devon can try and ask the question on
the live stream and get more information
yes
i mean it seems like this is kind of
just related to
general pdf export stuff which i thought
was already kind of being improved at
some point
um because there already sort of are
some issues with pdf export
so i mean the fundamental thing is they
want to do pdf export and have it look
like latex
um which it doesn't look particularly
like latex right now
well i mean i don't even know that it's
necessarily limited to pdf export
i mean i think there's you know people
who like the
printed guys guys the formatting
appearance of tech
we're speculating devon should get on
live streaming not all speculation i've
been dealing with
it for years okay so our conversion pdf
is dreadful
and as of 12 1 on linux it will crash my
machine
on a bad day that's that bad
who doesn't like the appearance of tech
and latex is there anybody who doesn't
like
it what
well clearly steven doesn't like the
appearance of tech because
otherwise we wouldn't be using sand
fonts for everything
well that's for a different reason
okay in any case the
yeah as christopher mentioned there is
an effort to
redo pdf export and maybe devin i think
can you make sure that i i don't know i
know that's one of the projects that
sushma
has on the list but can we find out what
the status of it is
yes i can ask her okay let's go back
what's left of that yeah go ahead one
more you know
just that it was last scheduled for for
12.2 whether it'll actually make it oh
okay
fine fine okay all right okay so good
and as of earlier this summer that was
content
no that it's run by shoddy's team
um so if sean has joined well that is
uh pdf export not pdf import
sean just told me that he's doing imp uh
import not xbox oh
completely different problem okay
we don't know okay can we can we go to
echo evaluation please okay so the
question
raised by giulio is what happens if
there's a nested echo evaluation
yeah it looks like it has a completely
totally similar label
if it's nested like if you for example
if you do
echo of one plus one and one of the two
ones has an echo
around right and and that's why we have
to use the labels to distinguish the
correspondence wait can you
do do you have to provide a label it's
impossible to do one argument one
you can but then the the the dilemmas
would be identical
why is this selection there's something
wrong with the selection of this
prototype
yeah and the prototype builds there's
something wrong with selection right now
but okay so
so there there is no nestability there's
nothing
nesting in that right which is kind of a
shame
well and by that you also mean it's
ambiguous
um
yes it is ambiguous isn't it i mean that
means they have to
it always has i mean i mean it's it's
it's an order of evaluation right
so parentheses this is this is
parentheses right it nests correctly by
parentheses i think right but
yes but well i guess i don't i'm not
sure what you mean by there's no nesting
but right it's do
it's printing them in order of
evaluation correct yeah so so we know
that those two are paired because
they're the innermost parentheses
right i wonder if there'd be a clever
way of making the
gillum that's like hyperlinks that would
go back and forth between matching
sets oh matching sets
okay you mean at least something which
hover
a hover effect or possibly a click
effect right no i mean like if you click
on the
you know one next to the one plus echo
evaluation
that it would highlight some way
highlight the one with the
cover
just on the subject of the latex stuff
could we make sure we had of an agenda
item
about string templates with latex
that with tech and also ethan suggests
this thing about a latex rendered form
added to the list of of star form type
things
i i don't 100 understand that but i
think we do need to think through a
little bit more of the programmatic
interface
to what is really quite nice that this
apparently added yesterday
capability to to do um uh
uh tech import in here so if we can get
that added to probably an ild agenda
devon okay so now what are we doing here
so
numbering them i mean the analogy with
our in out
that we could number the level levels
or number the actual i mean what do we
do if we have
different one thing is the levels the
other thing
is this goes in out in out and out i
mean because we might have a series of
these
yeah also by the way it's not
necessarily
parentheses because for example if you
if you call something
you know if i call uh url
download save i think it's called like
if you call anything that makes a
scheduled task or some sort of
asynchronous task
it's not guaranteed to be parentheses
when will it come back in the notebook
this will go to the message window
probably
in a task okay that's true right okay
yeah
i think it's just you're right it's a
parenthesis which might not have been
matching
is that possible that not have a
matching return if it returns null does
it not have a matching return
if i do this
that's weird
i mean it's correct the fact that we
suppress printing if
if the fact that we magically suppress
printing the result if the final out is
no doesn't change the fact that the
value of
percent is null
no i agree i agree okay
all right so look we've got nesting
we've got this case here both of which
are looking pretty terrible
i mean let me let me just do a nested
case uh how would i do that i would just
do what's an obvious way to do that with
a nest
here yeah no maybe am i
am i crazy or is that will that work if
i say nest
how do i do that how do i make a nested
collection of
echoes you can try to nest a
co-evaluation i mean they will report
each other
in the inputs you will see many experts
so with this if i say nest echo
evaluation
right yeah x5 right
okay that is truly hopeless wait a
second what
but those are going in out in out and
out maybe yeah maybe you should
make it some make make x something that
evaluates
just say x equals two but yeah you'll
probably see x2 x2 x2
or you can inactivate evaluation and
then activate the
the whole big expression at the end hold
on hold on one suggestion
we're just giving one suggestion here
what are you saying
that that i want to make the echo
evaluation
be something that evaluates here we'll
just just say
x column equals 2 in here x colon equals
two
no no just somewhere else just oh it's
about i i see i see i see i see
that'll be the first thing and then
you'll probably take xxx 222 or
something like that
yeah okay or yeah
so here do do the following stephen wrap
the the echo evaluation in an
active
this echo evaluation
and then activated at the very end
okay this is more like it right because
it's hold
so it's it's right
yeah i mean i understand what this is
doing more or less okay so you're seeing
the internal ones
and they are returning then you're
seeing a a final lowest
x and then the returns start coming in
this is absolutely unreadable
as it is right now why i mean the the
it was this based on the family of eco
function in general utilities
because they they had the eco eco holds
that
is using our rows to match input and
output
but i think that that echo though i
think that that one
doesn't print the in until it's finished
though until it's finished evaluating if
that makes sense yes
oh this is okay this is the reason why
okay i see
i mean that format is arguably you know
the nicest
format but you can't do it until you
have
until you know the result
unless unless we could i mean is it
possible
that does that have a long kind of
brackety thing coming down here
can i run it the yeah i can paste you
the
code if you want yeah can you it's gonna
be
i'm i'm also wondering if one could do
something crazy
like replace the cell right initially
print the
in the the input and
then replace that cell with the
bracket structure once it's done
yeah i understand i think that is as you
say crazy
what the heck does this mean you have
the internal one first
one goes to one and then the external
one
what's this box represent another echo
hold
the yeah the the the openable thing you
will have
in general you always have when because
the arguments evaluate before
the head i mean sorry before the
expression
so that echo hold evaluates to one so
you see the one but you see
where it was coming from
so if you call you know echo hold of
some complicated thing will it have drop
downs going all the way down
uh this it could very well be uh
what are you suggesting crystal say echo
hold of you know one plus two plus three
or sorry that's a bad example try um
you know do it even
actually i don't think that example will
work either just just try um
you can even try just one plus two times
three to the four
okay right if you if you go to that drop
down rule just keep going
no okay because it needed other echo
holds this is the only echo hold
that it's doing by the way i mean this
should be in the function repository
whatever this
thing is although it's kind of i think
it wasn't
okay but most of general utilities at
least isn't the function repository i
don't know about this one
well and i think i mean i don't know
this for a fact but the
the two times 3d you know the fact that
it doesn't go
lower than that may very well have to do
with
you know internal evaluation of times
right that it's not necessarily
you know making an extra call to the
evaluator so
general the top level code doesn't see
it but right
comment from ethan on our live stream he
wants a way to um
uh reroute echoes to a log file or
generally
disable them from displaying in this on
the in the session
and not completely unreasonable ask
i have the function quiet echo but what
about the idea of sending it to a log
file
yes that's a good idea
so how would we do that would that be an
option to quiet echo
no no no i was saying that quiet echo
can can
avoid them printing yeah that would be
very confusing
i mean if if um
i mean i i guess if what i guess what we
would
i mean if if you if you really want to
add the ability to do things globally
right then
all these echo functions would need to
take options
that default to some dollar variable
that the user could set so instead of
you know automatic or dollar or you know
look at that here's the point i think
the the objective is you've got an echo
it's just going to generate
just gobs of stuff right you would like
to be able to route that to an external
file
i agree that that will be useful the
problem is that echo right now is
tied to you know where the echo where
things are coming from for the echo
because they're in the notebook
if it's an external file you don't have
that information it's just like
it sent all that stuff out
you know it's a question do you want to
avoid
go ahead what are you going to say i
wonder if
well um
what's equivalent for print
there isn't we're not we well we have
that look in version one
we have you could change you can change
the values of dollar output but
um i don't think you can set
print you'll sell it to a stream right
and yes
that points to a stream to a file i have
no idea what that thing looks like
anymore yeah there it is so i mean
that is that is the thing i mean we
could imagine a dollar echo
we have a dollar echo what is it
it's the thing well it's documented
right it's the thing that echoes all
your inputs
to uh file
to a file right so there's a there's a
subterranean world
that is a third of a century old that
you know is reminiscent of unix you know
redirection
type stuff that allows you to specify
for your output i mean i have no idea in
a notebook this was this was
set up long before you know notebooks
were the only
only common interface i i think we have
i think we also have a dollar urgent so
i wonder
if we do so i wonder if maybe uh
echo could be made to respect dollar
urgent
and you know if it's not output
streaming
yeah i mean because that was that was
done that's you know stadera basically
that will be mapped in a terminal
interface to stadera which is not by the
way the stupidest thing
i we should check that echo maps itself
to stadera
on on a on a terminal interface do you
agree that it should
unclear if it should be standard error
standard out i
think standard out is probably but if
it's standard out you can't distinguish
where it's going
whereas if it's standard error you could
have a two greater than
some file and so on but if it's going to
stadero then
you know if you are using that inside of
a script and you're
calling it via run process or whatever
your diagnostic stuff may cause you to
error out in some way i mean
i think even more generally if look if
echo is at some level an updated version
of print
and you're calling print to produce the
output for your you know command line
utility
but i think if you're calling yeah i
think that echo is not that
distinguishable from print that echo
should bring to standard error and print
printed standard out i agree
right so fair enough okay i think it's a
separate question how you send things to
log files
we have not log files are an issue for i
mean we do have mechanisms for logging
for some of the
the things which happen in the cloud and
and uh
you know asynchronous tasks and things
like that let's separately put a thing
on the agenda to discuss
logging and echo and other places that
need logging go ahead
uh i was going to say that the uh dollar
urgent also
in a terminal is mapped to stat out and
not stead error
so um well that probably got done to fix
a bug
you know in 1989 or something who knows
right so i mean we could we could have
echo printed
dollar urgent and then if you want that
to be different from
let's put that in our discussion about
logging i don't know let's
let's not derail for that right now it's
a reasonable idea
okay devin do you have it yes yeah take
note of it
okay let's come back to our original
problem here which is how to deal with
the um you know this problem here right
okay this is a mess and how should we do
it
so one possibility would be you know we
could increase the number of guillermos
is that crazy you know the depth
nested echoes are not exactly your
commonest thing
could we simulate increasing the number
of columns is that easy to to code
no
okay and they'd push out to the left
is that is it possible to push them out
to the left
well no what i mean is that if you had
say two of them
the second one would be to the left of
the first
no what this would look like is shorter
willamette longer longer longer longer
right that's what i meant that they
would grow out
to the left they're not going to push
things in well they might not have any
choice they might not have a choice but
in that and it might not necessarily be
bad for them to indent
i wouldn't be horrified by them
indenting
now do we actually know the echo depth
does something know the echo depth
currently but it could be added
um okay and i think more gumas
is better than indentation because
let's say these are printed in very
different parts of the notebook
be easier to compare them see this is
the one with three and
this is the other one with three gimmice
oh i see what you're saying you mean if
there were interspersed
outputs here that weren't anything to do
with the echo
yeah all right now what would happen if
there's a label
as well as the so this would be
i mean it's also not terrific the way
this looks
input output i have a feeling that we
should change the color slightly
is there a an obvious way to change the
color and not have it be stupid
and out you know
i mean you could mirror input and output
and have bold and not bold
it's interesting
is that is that easy just something like
could somebody could believe i mean you
could probably select the label and do
command b on it
that was a very subtle change
well i don't think it's that subtle i
think it's a i mean um
you notice that the arrows on the left
are also pointing in different
directions
i do see that yeah that was sort of the
point i mean that
but i i find that visually very
it's not very compelling visually
no i think you want a color change or
something
orange and gray or
well we could try gray for the input
orange for the output
is that something that would possibly be
specified by the user
using like color data or oh you could
probably do that but that's pretty
overkill
i mean i think that the you know what we
need is the default
could you um billy could you try and
mock this and just but you know put that
in
in um uh well i don't know does somebody
know if the
colors are live in a style somewhere
these are the echo before and echo after
cell styles
but i don't know anything about style
sheets so if you edit the
you know if you edit that notebook style
sheet
under format
this is the most ugly thing in the world
we have got i hope this is modernizing
for 12 2 at least visually
okay what's the style name again
what was the style name again echo
before
and there's also echo after okay but so
you're saying
echo before now just go to
format and change it to like a red font
i'm going to change it to gray okay text
color
gray
and why didn't it change is that
actually a character and not a bitmap
or some text resource it changed on the
cell not the
label looks like no no okay
we don't know how to do it somebody
should figure it out
oh look it changed yeah i changed that
cell that was the echo before that
wasn't the dingbat that was the
thing itself by the way no no no no the
dingbat was also there but i'm saying
the dingbat is probably not
text yeah i understand but by the way
changing that to gray input isn't
terrible
yeah it's interesting
that doesn't seem bad at all
um
uh somebody's suggesting put the arrows
on the right for input on the left
output that will not work the input
could be arbitrarily long you'll never
see the arrow
um
i think that putting that that graying
that down
and putting this and correspondingly
graying that guillermo
is going to work and i think trying uh
deeper you know larger numbers of
golomeis even if they push things to the
right
is the correct thing for nested ones
i think that's what we should try um
okay uh with respect to this
different in out labels um
i mean i don't know if we use this
clearly we're burning the possibility of
having a label
which is a rule like that
right we were suggesting rules because
they
naturally represent which one is first
indeed a pair would be confusing
no i agree now what's this
in in in function out function
so that's a function that can be applied
before
and do we have that right now in echo
evaluation
yes but only for the input you see the
hold and the example above
yes
and well i think that's
sorry and the echo itself has an out
function yes
okay well fine these look okay to me
oh the old gray dog was saying to the
writer left to the
label yeah the problem is that we don't
always have labels this is the case
where there isn't a label
but you're suggesting if there is a
label
the question is do we put
no i don't think it's going to work we
tried that before
um
uh i yeah ali is complaining that that
orange doesn't look good on the white
background i think it looks pretty good
but i don't know what this does on a
on a dark mode uh notebook that's a
different question
all right i think we're done with the
echo evaluation discussion can we
continue please
on i know this is this is a very
kind of worms it's a longer discussion
yeah certainly we need to
review the recommendation so perhaps you
can leave it for the next time okay
but just just to give some sense of what
this is yes so these we are adding new
calendars
and in the process we are also adding
parameters to the calendars so we are
following the model of your projections
which are string comma rules with
parameter values i see
and how funky do these get
we have like 30 of more calendars
already
and parameters you have like i mean are
we doing the history stuff are we doing
the regnal calendars of
you know ancient civilizations and
things or not
not recognized yet but we have some
ancient uh
babylonia and sumerian
samaritan calendar things like that some
modern calendars
still used by people and some proposed
calendars like calendars which are very
regular all months have 28
days and they all start mondays and
things like that
huh so okay it's a funny one
is that really that is that the right
character set for
coptic calendar it seems surprising that
it's in
roman calendar roman yep i mean it's in
you know standard latin character set
but i don't know
um we we tend to transliterate most of
them so we have the same thing with the
islamic calendar in hebrew calendar is
where by default using transliterated
but
potential is that what people normally
change
it depends both are used frequently
for a lot of the calendars um but yeah
it's
it's something we need to investigate a
little bit in terms of extensions to the
type setting
yeah we probably should have both
options for the month name
and um maybe somebody does somebody here
know for example for the
uh hebrew calendar it's quite common in
u.s calendars to translate
um or actually actually to have both to
both the transliterated name
and the hebrew name and the name in the
hebrew alphabet
but but you would you would see it with
the hebrew name somewhere it wouldn't be
only somewhere on the page right they're
not next to each other in fact
they'd typically be on opposite sides of
the page since
hebrew is a right to left language oh
gosh yes
um
right
it's a question from bob here can you
scan egyptian hieroglyphs and translate
into english
i can we we now that we can do beyond
plane zero unicode i think we can get
egyptian hieroglyphs can't we
but i don't think ocr the ocr does not
exist it has not been trained right
does it neither is the translation
no no one has machine translation for
for like egyptian or
babylonia or any of this stuff acadian
is there a corpus big enough to make it
i wonder i don't know
yeah it's been tempt but it was not very
well developed what people aren't google
searching and hieroglyphics all the time
so that they can just
machine learn it that's a shame
i thought there was a stone for that
and apple is apparently including it in
the next version of their operating
system right
so yeah right by the way what is
happening to the the beyond plane zero
unicode in in the prototype build and so
on does anybody know
what what do you mean in the prototype
build i mean in the notebook system
here right
the question is how's the front end
handling it
yeah and i don't think anything is
changing a great deal right now about
that
i mean and that's maybe a code point we
just don't have
yeah right i understand can somebody
make sure
that it is on sushma's list of projects
uh the
extended unicode i don't remember seeing
it there
yeah i can check okay
okay so um even though i'd be kind of
interested to hear about calendar stuff
we should probably
um move that we should table it for a
different day in some calendar system
um
okay uh all right let's move on to the
um
uh i think devin you sent the lcc
calendar that means
i mean lcc agenda that may mean
different people
are needed for uh here so anybody who
thinks that they're not needed for this
segment
can depart
okay this is the kind of worms this is a
huge can of worms this is the value
queue discussion
so okay so i'm not sure how big of a can
of worms
it is but yes you can open the
uh the ref page into prototype build
and there are some relative some
relevant examples
futurized examples
so i'd like to know from christopher the
the what is the confirm
thing that is related to whether
something evaluated what what is that
called
well right now it doesn't exist because
we sort of determined that its behavior
is going to be too bizarre
um but i mean it would be called i think
i think we talked about
confirm evaluates and things like this
but we didn't have a proper name
i thought it was confirmed evaluation
but but maybe
maybe i'm misremembering yeah we talked
about several
yeah but so the the question is
okay just just to be clear what i mean
you know
um uh what is this
and i i think and i and just to be clear
i think
value queue is is is
you know serving a somewhat different
purpose
but okay but let's be clear what what
what the confirm evaluated
or confirm evaluates thing does
confirm evaluates would check that the
thing inside it
evaluates in a way where it didn't stay
the same as it was before
right and in that sense it is should be
precisely equivalent to the
trial evaluation method that's
documented in the table there
okay well so that's is that using same
queue
or is it somehow more sophisticated i th
the ian should confirm but i think it's
using
same queue correct now the only thing is
though is
we also mentioned this when we were
talking about it and i think
i mean look i agree i think the
confirming is a bit different because
one of the things we thought was that
maybe confirm
uh should actually just do the more
basic thing of checking if the head
changes because that actually has the
advantage that like you know
if i say x plus two and it turns into
two plus x it won't
you know it won't get triggered as hey
this evaluated
right which you probably don't want to
evaluate or you don't want to count
so i know there's complication for the
confirmed case that i think is different
for the value q case
well why is value q i mean is i don't
understand
value q one question is for value q
is did it go through user-defined down
values
that's a slippery slope because there's
plenty of system-defined stuff
that is using the exact same path as
user-defined um
uh well what do you mean by that i mean
right and we yes
what was yeah i'm not sure no i was just
asking
you about it using only user defined
down values
well i'm saying that
i'm not sure i do maybe the wrong
distinction yeah fair enough
okay but the the goal for confirm
evaluates
is this that one of the things that goes
wrong in people's computations
is that something they thought would
evaluate to 7.2 or something
uh just doesn't evaluate now your
argument is what they should do in that
case is to say
um what is it can confirm match is that
well the nice one we confirmed buy and
then number q or something
right i mean this is the this is the i
think that the fundamental point
is not even that case it's not even the
case that i expect a number out
it's just that you know there are
several different failure modes
for different sorts of functions and you
know and you kind of want to be able to
recognize each one of them
and one of those failure modes is it
returns unevaluated
although as we discussed it length
before there are also lots of times when
things are turned unevaluated even when
they haven't failed
so it can be many different things but
right right and the alternative that i
have been proposing for a while which
has been more or less shot down is the
messages off by default for particular
functions
right i mean that would be an
alternative approach although i bet that
there are
performance reasons why you don't really
want to do that if nothing else
anybody got to comment on that because
you know an off by default message would
just be
basically this function recording the
fact that it did nothing useful
anybody want to comment on that itai
i mean but the thing is is that some of
the time when functions return
unevaluated
they do this sort of very intentionally
where we're usually you know the
developers put a little wrapper
around some internal functions so that
it can return unevaluated
right and in those cases it would you
know you can imagine doing that but
sometimes it also just returns
unevaluated because of you know
pattern matching and stuff like that in
which case
you know it's kind of like where is the
message
i mean i mean like right
for a user-defined function it's not
clear okay so let's go back to value q
then
so what is the issue here so the issue
is
that the proposal is to put alternate
methods
in here is that right
yeah one of my pet peeves is value q
of positive five it takes five seconds
to let you know that yes it has a value
how could it do anything different
well if it looks and sees it there are
down values for pause
yeah and stuff like that it might be
able to
right so trial evaluation would wait but
presumably
symbol definitions present or something
like that would not wait
is that right exactly and this is using
simple definitions okay but if i say
pause of foo
right it's only at the top level but
what it pause the floor no
it's through the whole expression if
there's any symbol in the expression
that has
down values or up values okay so i'm
very confused by this why did i not see
a message and value q pause a foo
because i didn't run it right what did
it do
it just checked every symbol
and checked to see if it had the
appropriate to see if it had definitions
and if it if any of the symbols have
definitions
any definitions but foo doesn't have any
values
unless it does yeah point right right so
so one of the problems
with value cue just the idea of even
having a value q is that it has to solve
the halting problem right
yes um and and
so instead there are various heuristics
and
the current heuristic is does it have
own values
and if not uh let's just evaluate it
to see if it evaluated and the current
proposal
is hey can we be cleverer about this so
that we don't actually have to evaluate
the thing to find out if it would
evaluate
because if the user wanted to wait for
it to evaluate
to find out if it evaluates why didn't
they just evaluate it instead of calling
a function and then one at a value and
when it
gets true go oh i'll evaluate it now and
and it takes twice as long
how much code might be broken by making
such a change
could code be broken by making that
change
if people relied on value q of an
expression
what do you mean i mean of course they
have value curve and expression
well i mean sorry what would you i
didn't understand that
what what is the in the in the oh sorry
i was muted i've been talking all this
time and
and i've been muted which is why you
were ignoring me
um see the problem is it's either you're
too used to being a good
st
[Laughter]
yes uh well i it started at a very young
age blame my parents
um that's what the youngest child feels
like
um anyway uh
the uh um
i think you we asked your opinion about
something much earlier than this what
was the
the which you probably were also
responding about
um well okay no matter but keep going on
this
okay right so for
so let me maybe preface this a little
bit but that i think there are probably
two
sort of there are two cases we should
consider and i think there are also sort
of two cases in
practice um one
is uh you know value queue of a symbol
um and one
and the other is value q of anything
else
so value cue of a symbol the way it
currently works
is it looks at its own values and tries
to guess
whether that own value would apply and
if it and but it might leak as i've sort
of shown
in that case and what happens if the own
values aren't readable because it's read
protected and locked
um and the other method is sort of
and then it just sort of randomly
guesses
it it still knows doesn't it that it has
own values is that a true statement
sure but own values of of blah
so so the legacy method what what's
currently implemented in master which is
you know still more or less available as
the legacy method
um is it reads the own
values and tries to substitute them in
and sees
if the into hold of the expression
and then sees if that changed and
which of course can leak depending on
how complicated the downfall
that sounds completely crazy why okay
hold on
for own values of x i mean sorry value q
of x
you see if x has a known value the only
case which i can see being bad
is x colon equals seven slash semi blah
blah blah
with the thing it wasn't fire right
yep and that's exactly what it needs to
check yeah
right because as a as as the legacy
behavior is
does it evaluate non-trivially so
um right and now i think this case is
typically people really care
well has a value you know is there an
own value or isn't there and that's
certainly something we know whether or
not we can
read the own values of the
expression and
and so um the
now then there's the sort of more
general case where
you know you're trying to you might want
to know if this is a
a safe expression quote unquote and
right now the way that works
is well it just evaluates it and sees if
it changed then
that doesn't really tell you whether or
not it's safe because by then it's
already fired
so here so that's what symbol
definitions present
does it goes and looks through
everything and says oh does this have
up values down values own values or sub
values
um okay let's not look at numeric values
or format values that's
maybe something we could discuss if we
need to
say are they present but it does not say
whether the conditions are such that
they will actually fire
right correct okay trial evaluation does
what it does
own values present i mean this these
seem like sensible well-defined
possibilities
right and then the the one question is
sort of what should be the default so
one poss
so i think what we have implemented
right now is basically symbol
definitions present
is the default or you had implemented
for 30 years or not
no but we've had what
what we've had implemented for 30 years
is basically
trial evaluation with a little bit of
cleverness
for symbols
so it had side effects correct
that's horrific okay right and so
the one that you know the one case that
right should you know should value q
of sine give true or false
right so if we think if we think that
gives should give
true then we should just use symbol
definitions present
everywhere if we think that should give
false then
we should probably use own values
present for
by the way symbol definitions present i
mean we could detect that case of
whether
no we couldn't detect that case we say
nest of sine or whatever you absolutely
can't detect the case of whether
well the nest would have in other words
if if there is no possibility of getting
from the symbol
to to have the symbol in a down valley
position
then even if the symbol you get what i'm
saying if it doesn't have down values
and it can't get into a
even if it has down values if it can't
get into a down value position it's not
going to evaluate
that's true
but by the way i mean this documentation
should be changed to make it clear that
this is an insane function
[Laughter]
okay i'm thinking some sort of new
banner at the top that the
insane function uh it's like you're
what what was the function from uh
oh dear i'm i'm i'm going senile uh what
was your earlier language
um oh snp smp smp
yes what was that random right
right just thinking of the confusing
function
oh yes the confusing function what
i don't know what the well there was one
with the chameleonic
symbols and things they were no there
was a function called
confusing random numbers or something
like that to make things unique
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes
and the documentation was this is a
confusing function
great the um
right so so basically right so i mean in
the
case of you know list sine comma cosine
okay we couldn't
you know we'll give true which i think
is perfectly okay
um because i'm not sure how hard i'm
sorry true for what
for value q of that why
because because uh
there are symbols present which have
definitions
we can detect that case come on we can
tell whether it's in a down valley
position uh but
but we're but we're not only looking at
down values right
all right okay well listen why don't we
do this
why don't you put in what you think it
should be and
and somebody needs to look at the test
suite and see whether anything is
affected by it
okay okay let's try that
all right um do but
i i do want uh you know a quick opinion
the the value q of sine case right do we
for for if if we just do value q of a
symbol
do we only want to look at own values or
do we want to look at
i think we should just look at own
values i think that will have been a
common case in the code for years
and i think it's useful right and the
heuristic then for automatic will be if
what if the argument is just a symbol
use
symbol definitions present if the
argument is not just a symbol
use uh well what are we proposing use
trial evaluation in that case or what
well i think well the question means
present for the symbol but then symbol
definitions present
for any other expression yeah i think
that's probably right again i'm sorry
say that again
so for a symbol you would use own values
present
fair enough but for anything else you
would use symbol definitions
right check that with the route of the
test okay okay
okay all right let's move on we've got
several more things to cover here some
of which are quite big
okay wl is a documented export format
right so you know there's this so what
page
there's this export form thing that was
sort of invented without any
consultation from the import export team
um and it invented this thing called wl
which i guess is another name for
package
and that's used in some places
all cloud related as far as i know and
as far as ricardo's email also
says and so i guess the question is
do we want to have a format called wl
i think we should be there are wl files
so why not
um well we've been calling that package
for you know 20 years i know we didn't
have the wl extension
but when we had the m extension right it
was the same thing
i know i know but but i think that at
this point look we've got wl
i it's i think we should have wl
you know as equivalent to package
okay sean but it should link in the
documentation that's
i i think this is what is confusing for
people because
you don't see this far yes why not why
not just say and
double you should go somewhere that's
right this so you're saying it and so
whenever
we see wl as a format it should be
linked
to package well it says it's wl there
right but right and if you search for wl
it should come up because i made sure
right
okay so so the issue is whether we
should make the default
page the canonical page here be a wl
page
as opposed to a package page and i would
argue that at this point we should
and by the way these examples should
absolutely not have dot m in them
anymore
why don't we modernize this page call it
wl
make it make something which link which
which has this package page
can either just go to the wl page
or you know we could have i don't know
exactly how we document that go ahead
sean do you want to speak up we could
mark this obsolete
we just started working formats obsolete
fine i think it'll be fine and just call
it wl
going forward and for goodness sake
update the documentation here
okay um
right but you're not going to make
package stop working
no of course no okay
should we keep the double file in the
layout otherwise those examples will
yes keep them in the layout yeah okay
for the time being
all right um stephen one one one thing
we could do also for
editor already functions of the world
from repository they are doing something
like this but i think the indentation
option here
um we we
we should have a way to you know
basically do a damp of an association
with
list inside and make it look human
readable
so that is probably indented i well that
relates to the things we were just
looking at yesterday with code
assistance and this airiness parameter
for code formatting
so in other words having some way of
hooking into the code for answer does
sound sensible here
right that's what you're basically
saying is you're determining how yeah
yes sometimes i'm also encountering a
lot of
you know code and expression inside our
school
and you want to reformat it quickly i
know but that's a different thing
we just talked about that yesterday we
have a really nice scheme
for doing that hopefully with command
keys and things that gives you
reformatting
right but that's a different thing and
what i'm saying is that
maybe inside export i think you're right
yes i agree
a programmatic way to do that so that's
a connection that needs to be made
with brenton and the code assistance
team to make sure that export it's a
very good idea
actually to make sure that export can
accept those
those airiness or indentation options
so i i guess that's another thing for
devon to go go chase
okay it's a very good idea and i think
brenton
basically has the wherewithal to do that
and i just
will need to decide on some option names
or whatever element
names or whatever it is makes sense i
mean we might have an element name here
for wl
an export that is something like i don't
know what it would be and
you know wl and then i don't know
maximum airiness but that isn't the
right term but you know something which
which does what you say and breaks an
association onto
as many lines as possible in effect
right okay i i'm doing it all i mean
there are others from daniel and uh
guys guys we've got this okay ricardo
needs to talk to brenton
and try and come up with try and make
sure that ricardo likes
the the you know it's okay i don't need
to like it it's
well i think you should just clean this
yes
okay okay all right let's let's take a
look at this
yes ask one thing because there's a
similar issue that i just
thought of actually with uh cloud cdf
there's
that's also accepted as a as an export
form
but it's not a proper format what's a
cloud cdf
yeah is that even a thing anymore well
we don't really need it at some point we
thought it
would be a good idea but i think with
cdf sort of
not really being a thing anymore it's
all just notebooks
i think we could just move to nb
maybe we just de-document it i think we
should
i think we should because i think the
concept was that it was something that
had
embedded pieces that were in one form
um but were it was had a container in a
different form
and i think we're just not going in that
direction
yeah that that reminds me when you do an
export of a notebook
or you do an h no no wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute i'm
sorry
i'm sorry okay how do you do the
following i want to export a notebook
inside your embedder yarn
does that even make any sense in other
words i want to export something
which i would be putting on an html page
that is a notebook with the
i don't think it makes sense right that
would be an embed code not
an export correct
i'm not totally sure remember that but i
guess so yeah well let's talk that
through because i mean the fact is what
we want to be able to do
is i've got this notebook i want to get
it
so that i can put it on a web page okay
but that what's going to happen is
the notebook is going to be saved in the
cloud and then
some embedding code has to be provided
that will be the actual html to put on
the page
that references the cloud url of the
notebook
exactly yeah as far as the object is
concerned it's just a notebook
right but that's what cloud cdf had in
mind
was that that construction
you see what i'm saying maybe
i think that was what i had in mind at
least when i was originally
suggesting it was something
where it is arrives on a web page
but it is referencing a cdf
see what i'm saying it's a piece of html
that brings you a cdf
okay so the export form
is a little confusing there because it
is really an embed code
that is doing two things it is posting
something in the cloud
and then providing the wrapper code
yeah yeah if you want wrapper code to
embed it somewhere else and
embed code is the answer it's not a
separate format
i understand but the point the point i'm
making is
it would have been a format were not for
the fact that it essentially has to have
a side effect
of posting the core content to the cloud
right if you could have inline an
inline notebook in a web page then it
would be a meaningful format
see what i'm saying right
but isn't that just the html export then
no because well it depends depends what
the inline content is
and yes it basically is for the time
being until we have some web assembly
mechanism
for rendering notebooks on the fly and
so on
right if it has to go to a server look i
think this is not a thing
i don't let's not address this right
here i probably cloud cdf can be
obsoleted but i don't know
for sure if you could try and think
through these points that i've been
making about how do you
how do you export a notebook so that it
is showing up as an
embedded thing and and you know so you
can plop something into a web page
that represents the embedded thing
yep fine okay can we move on to progress
indicator and yarn you should stick
around for this because this relates to
the cloud as well
sure yep um and billy is billy here
we all need him for sure
somebody get him please he is he's here
he's here
he's just quiet apparently okay so
explain can do we have examples here
yes design has a bunch of examples
if you have seen most of them is just a
refresh to basically what's
it has been implemented what we
discussed last time
okay
and then the application example has i
think the the more complicated
one that you're uh can i run this yeah
in a prototype build yes
maybe i'm already an approach type build
here
okay let's see this go
what's all that [ __ ] running
it's frozen here should it be frozen
nope there might be some messages in the
message box
but by the way though i mean i i assume
that this is uh
i i guess in theory you can run this
without all of these
um other arguments right
you can run it alone but then it's like
monitor if you if you don't put a
variable
what are you monitoring sure okay
yeah i i don't have much context for
this project i've just
heard of it in passing but like uh my my
understanding was that it was it was
sort of that uh
you know a bunch of functions like map
and so on there's sort of obvious
progress indicators that you can have
and so you can just
the idea is you'd sort of be able to
turn them on in some way
yeah but then then we need this is
basically before that
this is the impression right okay then
we can decide what to do that
we can build stuff using this but the
point is
there was a lot of work to be done to
hook it up to the terminal to be sure
that
the whole dynamic thing was properly
done and uh
and now it's mostly done okay so then
this
is
so this function here is this intended
to be a user level function or not
no this is where we put the stuff that
we
need then we can decide how to package
it
okay fine okay design wise
i'm not that excited about having this
be so loud
this header yeah i don't i don't think
there was a
originally a background color that dark
uh yeah probably i think i copied from
what it was before in some general
utilities the amount of darkness
but as i put in one of the points above
billy i mean now that everything is in
place and implemented
we should probably meet and go through
these little details
okay okay so stop button is a
that all of these things provide a stop
service so to speak
nah not all of them no okay you have
you notice the buttons goes to stop in
the middle of the code
yep uh that is what provides and uh
you know the user needs to to
the user i.e the developer needs to
provide an
infrastructure because this is this
what does this do this closes it up to
something which looks more like
yeah for example in this uh this case i
mean this is all all
uh temporary but uh right now okay if
you scroll down yeah okay you can see
you can you can mark some
element is optional why am i getting
this
i don't know that could just be
prototype build
stuff yeah yeah
prototype build has many more assertions
on by default than
the than the normal build so
um
uh so by the way for the stop buttons is
the idea that it will
it will return partial results so that
it's basically aborting
no it will return partial results
okay so i guess they're for for some
functions right um
you have to be careful there aren't
performance uh
reasons not to do that right it's like i
remember
it's obtained it's not opt-out you have
to
to say i understand no right i'm just
i'm just saying right like um
for example and the function repository
is a function i i use sometimes called
dynamic map which is kind of like the
general utilities
what is it monitored map um but the
dynamic map has a stop button
that gives you partial results but um
i think it sort of had some measurable
weird behavior slash
slowness associated with it because it's
basically re-implementing map
at the top level with bags and so on um
yeah but yeah yeah yeah i mean that
that's that's gonna be it but even if
you stephen if you if you unrecognize
the example within dissolve
uh for example like if you just want the
progress like you have this and it's all
value yeah
if you you have an iconized uh inside
inside the code part
yeah so if you uh uniconize that
then you see that there is a step
monitor
which is uh evaluating something it's
not too expensive i mean the the
the append to is done every every
every so often but then if you want to
stop for example you need the one event
and one event is uh also very expensive
to end to the nd solve loop
so yeah these things they have a price
the i guess the
the reasoning here is if you want to
enable them
is probably because you have a
computation that is very long okay so
wait wait
wait so for nd solve is it going to have
this by default or not
uh that you have to decide whatever i
guess
i mean some stuff is less expensive like
just progress monitoring
is less expensive um
yeah right yeah i think the a more
precise answer to that question
is that we have been in communication
with oliver and oliver is experimenting
with what we can turn on by default
without
okay fine i think stopping an nd solve
is a luxury item and i would be
perfectly happy to have some option to
nd solve have to be used to get
something which is stoppable
right and then i think we talked about
this i don't know that we ever wrote it
up right but we talked about uh
like a i think a progress monitoring or
maybe that's a symbol that exists
already
no um yeah progress monitoring
oh option for and you solve exactly
well for any function right so you can
turn
you know if you can turn these off if
you don't want them
etc etc yes well you can turn it to
automatic or all and things like that
for different levels of progress
monitoring
right yeah exactly okay so what
so in this review what we are i mean
okay well so um
we didn't have specific questions you
said you wanted an update so
i do want an update yeah and i don't
like this i think this is
not really quite right this header here
okay uh billy can you can you provide us
with your mock-up
with the link to the mock-up in chat or
something so we can
compare um yeah i'm looking at now i
haven't noticed that i think that the
mock-up is the same color as a
as the main grid it doesn't change color
for the title
i think i got distracted by the the
information box
okay i see let's see that if we if billy
can paste that in the chat
that'll be good bob on our live stream
is asking about
a pause button that's
i mean the stop button means stop and
return
a pause button of which we have in
things like audio capture
works differently right right and i
don't know what a pause button would
exactly do
other than your computer is frozen in a
modal state
i had a prototype that i showed you once
that was
using a pose to entering a sub session
you didn't particularly like it no it
was horrifying
look the pause if one needs that it's
because the operating system
is um
you know one shouldn't need a pause if
unless the operating system is causing
one's machine to be eaten alive
one should be i mean i mean arguably
okay we could have an overall pause i
know how
how this would work software engineering
wise we could have an overall pause
under the evaluation menu
is that completely crazy
well it would have to
well that's really a question for john
and tom because right it would have to
send
a a signal to a kernel
to somehow it sounds like a thing that
should be the
responsibility of the operating system
what's that i thought we used to
essentially have that under evaluate
where i mean you'd basically well we had
we had to interrupt
and then if you just didn't do anything
it was effectively okay well the fact
that i didn't pay attention to that in
so many decades well you you in fact
ordered the removal of this button
apparently
uh and and there are people who are
unhappy about this but there
there was an interrupt entry there and
it's still available
i believe is command option period
on mac i think nobody knew what it was
oh well well todd did
um right and it i mean it's it's not the
i mean i think with a little bit of
cleanup it might be a useful
thing but it's it's you know it's not
exactly
the most important uh item
remember the only reason i can think of
using it is you know you're on a laptop
in your office and
you know you're going home for the night
or something and
it relies on you yeah being behind your
firewall or something
ornate that's an ornate case yes
um okay uh let's see we're looking at
this
yeah that looks a lot better
yeah i cleaned it up this is not an
issue
okay no problem um
a lot of blue
it is a lot of blue but i think it looks
pretty good
i mean mainly just the middle column
cases
this case here yeah
i wouldn't worry too much but i think it
looks pretty decent okay
also we have the the message here that
uh certain functions like
uh netrain or classify will switch from
uh with a heavy information version of
this
which is gray and that the so the
training version of this
being blue gives i mean it's more more
clear what's going on actually
that's what one is the output yeah yeah
right but the out
this is an intermediate stage and then
the output is an information blob
that is grey yeah okay
um reasonable enough
uh by by the way the the animation there
you given that you asked for it is the
prototype for dynamic image
oh sorry animated image so you can hover
on
those stuff oh that's going to last
guys like is this some crazy dynamic
thing or something but
no okay it's very nice
how does it work right now it's just
basically built on top of the same i
mean similar to list animate
without controls and uh like this is
fashioned
as far as the dynamic is is efficient
so uh it's one of those things you
probably want to
to implement i mean the point is if you
have data in memory is this yeah i mean
this is all front-end
this is purely this was copy-pasted you
don't even have this implemented it's
just boxes
so this was copy-pasted from the branch
that had it
what the thing i'm interested in is to
be able to do that on gifs
on the yeah exactly in the file uh i
guess i mean
john promised us library link support
for
sending image data directly to the front
end and we want to use it
extensively for out of core images video
so that that will be propagated here
nicely as well it's being worked on
i mean with the whole arm mac porting
effort given that
chris is you know pretty important for
both of these projects that
it may not happen for 12-2 but
it's being worked on no no yeah i mean
the reap the benefits would not be to
have to
john say that probably be at the end of
a release so
we want th this will i mean the other
functionality would be in 12 3 or
whatever
we have so but but i mean this is the
plan forward for this stuff
right and if you scroll up a bit i just
don't want
the progress since last time
uh since we're talking about uh
missing bits what is this
right so yeah so um
right on windows we we had we had like
i guess there are five uh terminals
listed there
which i think exhibited at least three
distinct behaviors if not more
okay but we got them all to work so you
know since i didn't want to be ignored i
i want the credit for that that's very
good
um okay a couple of comments on our live
stream add an option to try and
that will try to save intermediate
results on aborts
you mean where would they go though i
mean i understand
why it's something that you want but
i mean you don't even know necessarily
no no right right
it's i i guess it might be nice to have
something where it's like on abort
you dump everything that like i mean the
problem is that there might be things
that are in the process of being
modified
right i mean if if if we returned an
enol to
top level our users would be very very
very unhappy with the result
so i mean right once in the board is
right we
we start unwinding the stack and we
don't know what
state things are in so there's nothing
we can
safely return uh
to top level right did these stop
buttons
right the yeah that much more person who
created the progress monitor
says run this function to to interrupt
and then it takes care of all the
cleaning so look
the status of this is this is all
internal it is going into particular
functions that
have that are known to be long time
functions
um and it will come up when and then go
ahead
and and in particular where we you know
things which already have sort of ad hoc
we are
on the lookout for those to convert them
to this now standardized interface fine
okay so that's step one step two is
providing a user level version of this
interface
and step also two probably is installing
it in some functions like map
right which will be super nice and
import is another
big one
yeah right import of video already uses
this
um sorry export a video
uh there's many imports like importer i
mean like like one
that has a slightly tricky ux is the
drag an excel file or something
into a notebook that can take a while
or drag a big image those those should
have some kind of progress indicator
i don't think that that's this progress
indicator though no i agree i agree so
that's a that's an untethered progress
indicator
so that but that's another thing that
devon should be on your list for
progress indicators
but things that we're dealing with this
in this project are tethered in notebook
progress indicators
well tethered to computations not
necessarily notebooks
because it also works in a rock kernel
yes yes yes yes yes tell it to a
computation right so you have an
in while you're staring at the
the yellow bracket you have something
that's trying to tell you something
about what's happening
which is a distinct problem from you
did some arbitrary front end interaction
and now the front end is being slow
that's a that's sort of a different
yeah it's a different thing right yeah
um
uh okay um let's see a couple of
comments from our live stream and then
we really have to wrap up
uh bob is talking about having two
notebooks and you want to power it as
one calculation over another
that's up to your operating system that
is out of our hands
if you've got 17 cores you know which
ones get used is really an operating
system issue
um ic asks it possible to use
functions that have been compiled with
the new compiler
we are working on the problem is the new
compiler is is
produces incredibly efficient code but
is slow to run the compiler at present
and the main thing that's happening is
we're trying to compile the compiler
um and as soon as that works it will
become possible to do
just in time compilation and lots of
things um
and there's a bunch of other interesting
stuff afoot
with the compiler which we don't have
time to talk about right now
and bob complains he doesn't like thin
progress bars i think we
we really went through this i think
these look
pretty good we should um um
i don't think um uh
yeah i mean some some some applications
have thick progress bars some have thin
i don't i don't know what the um
our default progress indicators are
thick and i i i
i maybe see a little bit of that because
i think that often like
you know if you have some window running
and it's it's it's running some code for
a long time it's nice if you can just
look at it you have to strain a lot more
with the thin ones to see
right i think the issue is that it might
be a progress indicator that was really
kind of irrelevant you were
concentrating on other things in the
notebook
you don't want this giant thing that you
know you were just typing the next
part of the your you know great novel or
whatever
uh and cells below and there's this
giant thing happening above
that's a like a giant neon sign or
something
well but there is a giant thing there's
this giant blue box it's just a question
of whether the
indicator is where the blue box moves up
yeah right the question whether the
indicator is is right
although i i will say that we could
probably easily
double or triple that thickness without
um
you know really those things where
they're multiple indicators that's
another issue
the point is is that the actual size
right the extra size of the indicator
itself
is is the vertical size is so small
relative to anything else that right
space is not an issue for this yeah
right and
and i'm i'm a little i i would be a
little bit concerned about people with
any sort of color impairment
you know that difference in thickness is
really subtle so if
if you have color impairment that may
not be a readable
i assume that was checked somewhere but
i don't know
but all right listen the comments from
our live stream also from lith pointing
out
visceral satisfaction of seeing a thick
indicator
crawling across the screen why doesn't
billy just do a couple of experiments
with thickening these indicators
and see whether we can make something
work i think the reason that that
i mean you know the other issue is one
does sometimes have a stack of five of
these
that was another reason for having them
be somewhat thin it looks pretty weird
but the stack of of multiple thick
indicators i believe
well we don't have multiple indicators
in one
box not in one box but they can stack on
top of each other can't they
sure but again i'm not sure
that uh you know unless all we have
is the indicator and nothing else i'm
not sure
that uh they uh
you know again the thickness of the
indicator is the controlling thing
fair enough all right well let's try
thicker ones i thank you for the
suggestion
um we're not going to get to this okay
no it's not urgent it's it's waited a
few months already
so okay all right good work everybody
and thanks to folks on the live stream
and we'll see you another time